vamos a darle un repaso general a todo
lo que hemos visto de sistemas de
ecuaciones y en este vídeo creo que
sería muy bueno recordar todo lo que
hemos aprendido acerca de cómo resolver
los tema de ecuaciones qué tipos de
sistemas de ecuaciones hay o cómo
encontrar la solución del sistema de
ecuaciones por lo tanto deje de copiar
aquí mis dos ecuaciones con las que voy
a trabajar en este vídeo y dice 9 x
menos 4 y es igual a menos 78 esta es mi
primera ecuación y voy a tomar la
siguiente ecuación 4x más bien esto voy
a decir que es igual a menos 18 ya que
tengo mis dos ecuaciones y bueno
recuerdan que nosotros tenemos un
sistema que es consistente y realmente
nos gustaría tener un sistema
consistente si pasa es lo siguiente si
nosotros vemos la gráfica de estas dos
ecuaciones son rectas entonces vamos a
intentar hacer aquí las gráficas de
estas dos ecuaciones para ver a qué me
refiero con un sistema consistente
imagínate que aquí vamos a tener
nuestros dos ejes déjame cambia de color
para hacer la gráfica de estas dos
rectas o manu tal vez no la gráfica de
estas dos rectas pero al menos como un
esbozo de estas dos rectas
supongamos que aquí tengo mi eje de
leyes muy bien aquí tengo a mi x las
equis y lo que esperamos es que estas
dos rectas se vean de la siguiente
manera
supongamos vamos a suponer que está así
se ve la primera recta ojo es un esbozo
quién sabe si realmente se ve así pero
bueno vamos a suponer que esta es la
gráfica de mi primera recta y no voy a
tomar la gráfica de mi segunda recta y
también vamos a suponer que es algo así
realmente no quiero que sea
completamente real lo que quiero que
veas es que lo que esperamos en un
sistema de ecuaciones es que tengamos un
punto de intersección cuando tenemos un
punto de intersección tenemos un sistema
consistente y tenemos una única solución
porque este punto de intersección es un
punto que a nosotros nos interesa mucho
voy a ponerlo con rosa para hacer más
énfasis este punto de aquí es muy
importante para nosotros porque este
punto nos dice que satisface a ambas
ecuaciones como está en ambas rectas
pues es el punto de intersección
entonces cumple tanto la primera
ecuación como la segunda ecuación y por
lo tanto es la solución
sistema de ecuaciones porque cumplen
ambas ecuaciones así que bueno para
hacer esto habíamos utilizado varios
métodos de método gráfico sustitución
suma y resta igualación sin embargo en
esta ocasión quiero verlo por el método
de eliminación por dentro de su me
restan así que para esto lo que quiero
hacer es eliminar la yema y fíjate qué
es lo que necesitamos es que en la
ecuación de abajo aparezca un 4 y para
que se se elimine con el menos 47 la
ecuación de arriba así que voy a
multiplicar la ecuación de abajo por 4
me queda 4 x 4 x 16 x 4 porque es 4
james y menos 18 por 4 lo cual es menos
72 muy bien lo único que hice fue
multiplicar la ecuación de abajo por 4
porque porque si ahora yo escribo aquí
la ecuación de arriba la primera
ecuación entonces ya voy a poder
trabajar con estas dos ecuaciones dejen
poner los 9 x menos 4 james es igual a
78 negativo a menos 78 y es que esto es
muy importante porque aquí ya tengo dos
ecuaciones las cuales cuando yo el asume
voy a poder eliminarla
y utilizan los métodos de summers están
se eliminan ayer y que me queda 16 x + 9
x es lo mismo que 25 x muy bien después
más 4 y menos 4 james se eliminan
semanas esto se canse de 0 y por lo
tanto voy a poner 0 + 0 y esto es igual
a menos 72 menos 78 entonces si son
positivos se volvería 80 más 70 150
menos 150 entonces estos dos me dan
menos 150 y ya tengo una ecuación con
solamente una incógnita una ecuación
bien fácil de resolver 25 x es igual a
150 negativo no olvidemos el menos y
ahora te voy a dividir todo entre 25
entre 25 entre 25 y que me va a quedar
25 y 25 se van estos dos eliminan ojo no
olvidemos el menos y aquí me queda menos
6 150 entre 25 es 6 y con este menos el
menos 6 x vale menos 6 y bueno una vez
que ya tengo el valor de x pues ahora
vamos a investigar cuál es el valor de
james y para eso voy a utilizar la
ecuación de acá abajo
en la ecuación de trabajo voy a
sustituir el valor de x para poder
despejar allí y me quedan 4 por menos 6
porque x vale menos 6 margen es igual a
menos 18 4 x menos 6 pues esto es lo
mismo que 24 negativo menos 24 más james
es igual a menos 18 y ahora si yo sumo
24 de ambos lados de la ecuación me
queda que es igual a 24 menos 18 lo cual
es 6 positivo es decir que ya tengo la
solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
cuando x vale menos 6 y 6 tengo la
solución de este sistema de ecuaciones o
dicho de otra manera el punto menos 66
es el punto de intersección de estas dos
rectas y fíjate que no era este punto de
aquí las rectas estaban un poco
desplazadas hacia abajo pero bueno
realmente lo que quería era hacerte un
esbozo de estas dos rectas y realmente
solucionar el sistema de ecuaciones que
ya tengo aquí la solución por lo tanto
vamos a borrar la pantalla y vamos a
hacer otro ejercicio a ver tomémonos a
la siguiente en el siguiente par de
ecuaciones no voy a tomar la ecuación
menos 7 x ya es le voy a restar menos 4
james y voy a decir que esto es igual
esta es mi primera ecuación vamos a
cambiar de color y mi segunda ecuación
es x
+ 2 james y esto voy a decir que es
igual a 3 y ahora si me voy a preguntar
cuál es la solución de este sistema de
ecuaciones y pues bueno a mí me gusta
mucho el método de suma y resta así que
vamos a hacerlo otra vez por su me resta
pero esta vez voy a eliminar a x y
preliminar x date cuenta que lo que
necesito es tener un 7x de tal manera
que cuando yo sume con este menos 7x que
tengo de la primera ecuación se cancela
la x por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer es
multiplicar adecuación de abajo por 7 y
que me quedan 7 x + 14 james esto es
igual a 21 esto me sale de multiplicar a
la segunda ecuación por 7 y la primera
actuación le voy a poner tal cual menos
7 x menos 4 james es igual a 9 y ahora
sí vamos a sumar las para ver que me
quedan estos dos se cancelan 7 x menos 7
x se van vámonos
después me quedan 14 menos 4 y es lo
mismo que de james y por último 21 más 9
30 es lo que me dice que james es igual
a 330 entre 10 estrés
y bueno ahora voy a utilizar la segunda
ecuación para despejar a x2 por 13-6 me
queda que x + 2 es decir más 6 es igual
a 3 o dicho otra manera x es igual a
menos 3 entonces puedo concluir que el
punto donde se intersectan estas dos
rectas desde el punto menos 33 o la
solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
essex igual a menos 3 y igual a 3 y
bueno este ejercicio estuvo muy fácil
tan fácil que se me ocurre hacer otro
ejercicio por acá abajo vamos a borrar
esto y vamos a copiar el siguiente
sistema de ecuaciones que dice me voy a
tomar las ecuaciones menos 3 x menos 9 y
esto lo voy a ser igual a 66 y por otra
parte tengo menos 7 x más 4 y esto lo
voy a hacer igual a menos 71 y date
cuenta que aquí no está tan fácil
eliminar a uno de estos dos términos lo
primero que quiero que veas es que lo
voy a resolver por suma resta pero por
la suma y resta que yo le llamaba por
multiplicación de una constante es decir
que si yo quiero eliminar de aquí el
aiem esa va a ser mi elegida
solamente estoy eligiendo porque una es
positiva y la otra negativa entonces
tengo que multiplicará la ecuación de
arriba por 4 y por otra parte al trabajo
por 9 y se multiplicó primero la de
arriba por 4 me queda 4 por 3 es 12
menos 12 x menos 36 james y 66 por 4 es
lo mismo que 240 más 24 que es 264
perfecto menos 12 x menos 36 james es
igual a 234 y si yo lo que quiero es
cancelar el aliento estudio multiplicar
la de abajo por 9 y que me queda 9 por 7
63 63 x 36 james es lo mismo que 9 por
menos 71 esto está fácil 9 por 19 9 por
7 63 mil 639 perfecto y ahora si vamos a
sumar las que me quedan menos 12 x 63 x
es lo mismo que menos 75 x después de
aquí tengo menos 36 ya más 36 ya se van
y después por otra parte tengo 264 menos
639 y bueno como éstas más grandes lo
voy a poner abajo y lo voy a restar y
que me queda de la resta de estos 2 639
- 264 y el resultado lo pongo negativo
94 y 56 para 13 y entonces éste se
vuelve 56 para 13 7 y 5 menos dos estrés
perfecto pero como el negativo era más
grandes entonces me quedan menos 375
menos 75 x es igual a menos 375 y ahora
sí divide ambos lados de la ecuación
entre menos 75 me va a quedar que x es
igual a amd y bueno 75 cabe cuatro veces
en trescientos y cinco veces entre 175 x
es igual a 5 perfecto ya tengo el valor
de x ahora lo que quiero saber es el
valor de ley para eso voy a utilizar la
primera ecuación y voy a sustituir el
valor de x que me queda menos 3 por x
pero x vale 5 menos 3 por 5 menos 9 y es
igual a 63 es decir menos 15 menos 9
james es igual a 66 y ahora voy a pasar
el 15 del otro lado y me queda que menos
9 y es lo mismo que 66 más 15 que es 81
y por último que es igual a menos 9 81
entre menos 9 me da menos 9 y por lo
tanto el punto
sección de estas dos rectas es el punto